hello and welcome to another episode of
top 5 scary mods of the week Lucy's
returned she's back I can't get rid of
her
hello JJ hey man I sit next to you you
definitely can't get rid of me
I definitely gone also we call her JJ so
yes please do JJ how difficult was it to
get this episode of Skyrim to start
working there was a lot of swearing oh
yeah
I am NOT very good with the whole mod
kind of thing so I left that up said I
just saw talked Woodley here in the
corner just try to be really silent and
encouraging um yeah I feel like I helped
by playing you know obnoxious Australian
prank video you say that yes yes you did
so a short story mark Walton managed to
squeeze the original graphics card that
we were going to put in our new Skyrim
PC into the PC that he got a new one
it's very pretty the only problem is he
installed it crudely and then left to
America leaving it sort of but not
entirely working let's see how it goes
let's test it out with mod number one
well they see welcome to Rifton and I'm
not sure if you know Rifton very well
but something seems different goodness
what is this it's Christmas yeah it's a
climate overhauls summer winter tropical
we have gone as you probably guessed for
winter this is like tropical for
Newcastle yes this is tropical for
England there's leaves there's color it
has three different options you have to
choose the one you want you can make it
all summery and beautiful and rich color
but we don't quite a lot of that
recently we've done tropical so I
thought we'd bring winter to the
entirety the entirety of Skyrim and in
fact if you even go down some map oh
look at the map the map is covered in
white everywhere not a drop of color of
the wintery places extra wintery are
they like they like lost in snow can
confirm that in fact this place is less
wintry than anywhere else there's like
one snowdrift and that's it the rest is
oh they do have icicles though yeah but
you know they feel like they escaped the
winter they've somehow maybe they're
shielded are they more prepared for it
is it's like the Swiss ten mate metres
of snow falls and everyone's like well I
guess we'll just keep on living our
lives and then here in the UK there's
like an inch of snow all hell breaks
loose all transport fails and people die
the government warnings out on how to
stay warm yeah turn the heating on poor
guys are so underdressed for this you
weren't ready for the quick onset of
winter I understand why you're so upset
like you don't even have a shirt on you
fool
here this will heat you up Kevin of
course doesn't feel the cold no no no he
was born in the cold raised by it yeah
this it this feels more like Icelandic
you know it's like ya know everywhere
yet these lovely hot pools complete with
skull Giants girls definitely like I
yeah and just like Iceland take a load
off
hmm let's come and sit here
bathe in the bubbles oh oh that's nice
that's tingly that's nice on my
battle-hardened
I bet it smells like sulfur right the
but yeah as what that for a ringer oh
there's a character called Lucy in the
lion which there is she's she's one of
the well she's the youngest ones the
good ones is here's a [ __ ] and a sword
here's a bow that will kill anyone and
always hit its target and here's a
little bottle yay I'll be trusted with
that can I not get like a gun or
something no all the summary bits now
winter and for any of the others you
could say well I had a look at like the
picture of the tropical one it was in
Markov and it looks like because you
know it's how it was all like on levels
and stuff yeah cool into woven it looks
like a lost jungle temple oh it's
awesome so depending on whatever you
want
pick your favorite install it it's
pretty cool and recommend coming for mod
number two and Kevin has arrived at
bleak falls Barrow a majestic hunter in
need of a new bow and that's the name of
this week's mod it's huntsman bow
huntsman bow i insanity sorrow we use
some piece mods in the past he's very
good anyway we're a bleak falls Barrow
which means we need to blast our way
through kill a load of folks and get
some sweet loot so let's go do that
whoo oh wow that was actually really
good the trick was just enough notice
what sorry friend
oh sorry friend there's no dignity in
death none at all
we've arrived hey damn that was hard
there we go done hey there's a bow hey
we found a bow a bow you might get it
say like an archery range when you go on
holiday with your family design fine
craftsmanship no yell it there's a
little lion on the bottom because
Lannisters and lion on the top because
Lannisters oh yeah very pretty so that's
not the only part to this bow so this is
like the Sims of the bow but in order
for it to be really good you have to get
the expansion's what's happening to the
huntsmen it reached level 2025
oh my good nothing that easy all right
keep your eyes peeled for a kid okay
on it found the kid Oh Nick that's cool
it's got a little unique box
uh-huh is this jump huntsmen upgrade kit
Oh adorable what a niche item to sell I
not even sell
apply upgrade yes yeah all right and
apparently it has a visual change so so
here's a oh there's a wrapping on it oh
that was a big box just for some you
know straight well doesn't matter we've
upgraded a little bit and it's almost
doubled in values
odd corpse corpse again why did I do
this time that's right before we get
arrested let's just find out if the
earth
well huntsmen very good all right you
guys could be quiet that I'd be grateful
we're looking for boxes stuff your plot
and it's I tell you it's not evil it's a
just a box they found the books oh it is
look at ha oh very stable look at that
get the cheese kept cheese the cheese
nice it seems like a curious way to
scatter one's upgrades for one
particular bow maybe they're like the
Dragon Balls they naturally scatter
every time they're brought together you
get to fire one arrow and then it all
disintegrates again alright is it this
unboxing table no on the seat on the
throne not on the throne
y'all huh [ __ ] see ya he had a boozy
one last night guys sister don't look at
me got a stabilizer we've got our
wrappings where he's gripping nice and
tight we've got what looks very much
like a viewfinder yeah we've got a
quiver attached on the edge we've got
all this fancy stuff all the way up the
main shot it'll work oh it's a beautiful
beautiful piece of kit all right you'll
kill people now I think we should
probably kill some people with it now
ah that's delicate work this pretty
accurate alright very effective for
killing Wow good at this whoo-hoo sorry
Gramps writin LASIK yeah that really
didn't deserve to hit yet that was good
alright and then he could be my brother
yes my brother Oh seems to fire that's
pretty good pretty damn far
and welcome Lucy to mod number three
which this week is man moths it's my
greatest fear yeah whatever you're
picturing in your head right now you've
probably pictured it right if Skyrim
wasn't already dangerous enough with all
of its wild dangerous things and Giants
mmm especially Giants picture a mammoth
and a man synergize it's like a like a
Hagrid kind of situation hmm I don't
really want to know how it happened so
man and a mammoth copulated wrong once
what are they what is that found have
found Oh what the hell Oh why is the
wise one of them man myth real man myths
and more water well they do move in
herds ah I hate it I hate it I hate
everything about my friend oh why is
this one red I don't know well spawn
whatever - its back leg what's with its
shoulders it seems to be able to like
gesture with them why is it shaking
ah I hate it run run it looks like an
inbred cap maybe new songs will be
friendly oh it's so fast
oh my god I hate it I absolutely hate it
and here we see the man miss grazing at
the lake oh good I'm glad that that's
someone in hell spawns is it what is the
answer
ha ha it's like centipedes has a monster
I hate it Oh
oh thank god they died I mean it's today
what what do they carry hearts deidre
Daedra hearts what does it remind it
feels like something clean out of you
know like a studio ghibli thing you know
kill it kill it dead
it's just like every day at the office I
don't like it get it kill it it just
looks emotionless every ones we like dr.
Manhattan yes
Watchmen yes that's exactly what it's
like now I shrugged it off oh my god oh
nice you can that's it is it is this a
boss one yeah it's called an omen ma
yeah an omen moth oh it's the boss the
breeder of them all
it's the godfather of the family huh
quick eat his heart before he can
respawn YUM
no I don't think anybody does all right
well then Monmouth's if you decided you
want a crime against life huh in your
game this is the way this is where you
can add it
complete with omen moths and man mouths
and immune system ah
what a beautiful night sky look at that
hmm what a perfect night to be Undead
what a perfect night be undead indeed
and show off mod number four what is it
it is awoken we've awoken another
playable race noise the other the very
short undead what do you want to be lady
lesbian lady skeleton a knee skeleton so
a legless skeleton the bone yeah skin
tone Lord put the e on the end cuz then
it's like the singer oh that's nice yeah
she's got a dead looking face as well Oh
legs oh we can't float being kind of all
you do have like tip little ghost legs
kind of little glowing red eyes very
very nice are we dressed kind of looks
like dr. doom nope makes no difference
at all so there is a nice little little
home to Marius Oh Casey the tomb home
and how exactly does one get to - no we
have a spell home sweet home
god what a mess Wow okay uh uh-oh
this guy draaga pal this is my husband I
guess so I mean hey handsome like yep No
hey baby
no just doing his literature thing
that's that's cool that's cool
ah you know simple this stuff that I've
stolen off all it's a little tiny spy
darlin collectibles um wish to master
the arcane arts uh hurt me why not Wow
okay I can drug-free dragon priest
draaga Archer frostbite spider so
Shadowmere one spine please repair your
spine using these bones for a stamina
bonus at 500 yes a cure for bone-itis -
um the constable shape-shift into a pair
a dragon priest draaga we can become
anything um um oh yeah YUM all right
like sweet ah like you're grouped take
the bees the bees
hey that is it one with the bees and
that well Elise are mighty wooden fists
can't be messed with
we're spider my god oh no yelling for a
dragon proceed we kind of hope he'd be a
little bit more powerful
it's a sparks are a bit now yeah he's
not it doesn't seem like he's committing
my singing nothing being a dear can't
fix take take that you're gonna lose
take the mooing of a lifetime
ah come my woodland brothers assist me
finally fever normal thanks pal
Shadow Man oh look at him go
good work let's just bring in a dragon
priest he's brought his own stuff in
results results all round done very
effective work mr. dragon priest Kevin
man Nord strong a priest that is not my
name's know her at all he's bandit
plunderer what how deep does the rabbit
hole know I feel like maybe I need to
destroy him I've created a thing I can't
control who has their own ponderer I've
created a monster
and just in case that tomb wasn't homely
enough for you we have a second home
option in mod number five in illest
'real Bosma inspired tree house which
happens to be our user voted mod as well
so let's go and check it out it is of
course frosty as ever here because of
our mod number one this looks like maybe
it was designed for a slightly more
summery affair yeah it kind of feels
autumnal you know what it reminds her of
it's kind of a bit lost more E&E lots of
archery training or the trees stuff one
thing I have noticed and I think I think
it's part of the mod is that there's all
this wildlife cuz he's just sort of
hanging out he isn't really anything
he's just he's just foliage are some
chickens no they're not chickens they're
just props extras illusions if you will
all right let's head on upstairs real
butterflies though catch bees hi bees
now swing free swings I want to eat I
want on uh uh how do I get up to you
know swing for you can I hit it with the
bow will it will it swing as a swing
will it blend
oh no it's not swinging delicious oh
gods God we're gonna make such a super
tonight
oh it's soup night no we're gonna have
some undead gazpacho it'll be little a
dishes 'la dishes lid dishes over and
over this side we've got a be armchair
we can go in like just hang out this is
where I'll sit and watch my grandkids
house this is a lovely view water Jason
oh pretty it is it's stunning
very very tidy very pretty as well I
wanna live here you can live here Lucy
in Skyrim oh you can craft some arrow
arrow crafting station absolutely doing
that okay um well that's gone well notes
on our crafting okay okay any greeting
for crafting high-quality arrows of
various effects of good quality hunters
arrow on toes arrows are elven class and
crafted by anyone with enough knowledge
and smithing and then once you've got
the arrows here are all the poisons you
can make paralysis fungus poison arrows
dancing font arcane enchanter everything
you could possibly want
oh what a room looks like my room at
home and another mannequin that's what
everyone wants at the bottom of that bed
Oh a little what's this a little hot oh
it continues oh it could be hot Oh in oh
it's for the kid oh well the guests it's
cozy it's cozy no you don't want to
overdo it
no you know a few weapons just in case
just for the kids
and uh and a grotto let's have a look in
the grotto harvest a poison bloom lovely
oh I think I like the grotto the most
take Galadriel what was that Galadriel
the bow ancient bless bow for the
follower of Qian Qian Aras yeah well I'm
not gonna lie you're not as pretty as
the Huntsman no but you shoot arrows so
I can't complain work trying to pee on
it this is cute
Hey finally we're healthy again people
good people will stop commenting on it
now nope still bad though what's that oh
the mystical water heals you and cures
even more diseases yes quite deep as
healing fonts go and I know my healing
phone yeah you could drown in this
healing fun you know that you know what
that a heal you are what treats are here
living that's a little kind of you know
about and a Bandstand thank God finally
someone put a bandstand in Skyrim was so
desperately needed look we can build our
own things use Forge please is he just
punching it yeah with my fear so on such
a starry night is this you'll never be
able to miss
your Posner inspired treehouse because
it's glowing like so many fireflies
unfortunately nobody thought to put one
over the entrance maybe that's to
discourage thieves definitely thieves so
you can come up here at night thieves
and murderers
ilex it there come take a seat and
survey your land mammoth
man that's everywhere why oh it's
mammoths versus mammoths chickens
chickens will help why is the madman
still alive mammoths are invulnerable oh
I hate it I hate it with everything so
right there we go oh thank god oh all
right I think we did good well I hate
mammoths they're really terrifying and I
hate everything about them yeah just to
make it clear you found that one I did
yeah not me so I take no responsibility
whatsoever for whether or not you put
them in your game yeah it seems a little
bizarre that all of our non Kevin based
characters are completely immune to the
chickens
maybe maybe it's just because Kevin's
Kevin's special he is special he is at
one with the ticket it is in fact
something that I've seen a lot of people
post in the questions and in the
comments saying how do I make my
character fly with the exploding
chickens clearly it's a problem we now
have to so there we go when I find out
the exact answer to it I'll let you know
but until such time we have the comments
and the questions Lucy who is the first
comment from it is from the tolerant go
to the tolerant one thank you the weapon
of choice for a man like Kevin van Noy
and this picture my god
it's beautiful the fact is being held up
like that makes it seem like maybe that
was from an evidence Hall looks like
it's in a police auction it means that
someone somewhere commissioned that
weapon that said I wanted all gold and
with wood trimmings all done very
decoratively and and this is very
important it
have a chicken on the barrel yeah right
where the thing that makes it even
vaguely accurate would normally sit I
mean what do you look down the beak I
don't know yeah I guess next question
comes from David let crow here what a
name a lot of guys in one cheese yeah
thanks may want to get that one looked
at changing why can't we will make a
Dark Souls combat Skyrim mod that's a
good question I'm sure so a combat mod
though specifically what I'm assuming by
that you mean something that makes it so
desperately hard that you die over and
over and over now
scarves quite a big game especially when
you add in mods I think if you were
dying as often as you die in Dark Souls
you probably you could be looking at
never ever completing the game in your
life I'm sure someone's done it if they
have feel free to let us know in the
comments as well last week we asked what
we were asked cam and I were asked what
world from film or books fiction or non
would we live in ok um we failed to come
up with an answer in fact the only one I
could come up with was Pacific Rim which
is why frankly the worst world you could
ever want to live in because my mind
went blank so we asked you to tell us
where you'd want to be oh I like this
one at Pokemon the pokeballs would
probably now that I think about it be my
top one the idea of like walking around
and then just that be like mines ok so I
hate them wasn't mr. mime actually a
woman what I'm gonna google it comment
is help us out here the Ranger's
Apprentice I can't say I know that one
but why not avatar was quite popular as
well I see you jakesully men in black
that would actually not be bad although
I mess you were a Madi blag yeah we also
had Star Wars yeah kind of obvious I
guess and the last one should be close
to your heart
Mass Effect I would live in must be yeah
it might be in the Alliance maybe sans
Reapers so so on a Spartan dwarf said
the second question about which book
film well I would live in came up and I
knew the answer definitely middle-earth
on middle efforts were there another
very popular one and that reminded me
j.r.r tolkien died at aged 81 aged 81
the initial Skyrim level
was 81 conspiracy the opposite of sky is
earth what the opposite of rama's middle
is it guy rim equals middle-earth
Tolkien wins again I'm off to live in
the Shire good night precious that's
just I don't know if my mind is blown or
yeah earth middle-earth yeah live in an
earth middle yeah oh yeah earth middle
sorry right right that's pretty good
though it is great thicken it fellas she
like at least directed they'd left it
sky recalls middle-earth half-life 3
confirmed perfect and lastly one of them
mod creators that we've shown off one of
his mods in the past which was kevin van
Nords tools of the trade which he
custom-made for us which is very very
cool asked me if I could come and record
some scaring with him and so I did
you can go check that out at tinyurl.com
forward slash mod chronicles which is
his show on YouTube that's awesome but
after that we've also got the votes oh I
apologize I did kind of put the vote
link up really late last week but it
doesn't matter a slack handful of you
voted anyway and we got the Bosma
treehouse hmm so this week I'll try and
do better which is the first one JJ
first one is deception of the golden
chicken tell me anything about this it
has golden chicken in perfect the second
one up for the vote is Thunder child
epic shouts and immersion a big big bowl
full of a lot a big bowl full of emic
okay and third Infinity Blade mod for
skyrim is it my boy epic made by epic
cliffy B in Skyrim I'm sure that's the
ball can we just get cliffy B in Skyrim
those three are for the vote make sure
you cast yours by going to tiny or Elcom
forward slash ready semi blog and feel
free to berate myself and Lucy wait what
yes yes uh Lucy also where's cam where
is cam where is cam I think he's at is
he is he preppy he's packing because
where are you off to we're going to
Paris yay then I'm going on holiday so
I'm working at Lucy James game at Lucy
James games I'm at Ready Steady Go
and you can always use our hashtag which
is GS
Skyrim awesome thank you again Lucy for
bringing man moths into my life into
your nightmares mmm
we will be back here next week maybe
with cam who knows I would quite like to
get you and cam in on a show mostly
because it you know it's it's your turn
we will see you back here next week stay
tuned for more top 5 scary mods of the
week
you